there's this whole trend of the women
getting less hot on TV to be more
relatable and I would argue it's because
they're making movies and media for
women now instead of men yeah because
all the men movies like Transformers who
was the chicken there yeah I don't know
your name it was Megan Fox oh yeah oh
yeah of course yeah and now she's kind
of washed up now but yeah and Margot
Robbie like in her prime was in Wolf of
Wall Street and now she's Pastor Prime
she's in movies for women yeah so now
she's in Barbie y so um yeah so Victoria
Secret made a a huge blunder when they
decided to put fat
chicks um how can they not see this
coming I I don't know